hello everyone welcome today's to
today's live broadcast and linked
glycosylation profiling rapid separation
techniques for the analysis of a
development phase therapeutics
glycoprotein I am Matt salem of science
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
labyrinth and sponsored by sy X's
separations division for more
information we encourage you to visit
sigh XCOM /c e we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the events you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button in the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can at
the end of the presentation you can
enlarge the slide window by clicking on
the screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you have
any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem through the green Q&A
button in the lower left this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over please click on the c/e
button located in the bottom left-hand
corner of the web page and follow the
process of obtaining your credits I when
I like to introduce today's speaker
Laura Salmeron laura has more than 25
years of experience working in clinical
and biotechnology fields supporting
protein therapeutics she received her BS
in biochemistry and molecular bio excuse
me biochemistry and microbiology and
medical technologists from University
autónoma of Guadalajara Mexico she
worked in RX medical labs in monrovia
california for five years thereafter
owning a clinical laboratory in hospital
san jose in tijuana mexico in 1995 she
joined by Odin high-tech as the
analytical sciences group then moved
into the analytical development as the
lead for the San Diego site where she
worked for 15 years in 2011 Laura joined
the drug products group at amgen
Thousand Oaks
as she as the process lead for epogen
program then transferred to the
stability group as lead for all bytes
molecules in 2015 Laura joined halozyme
therapeutics in San Diego California
working with haloes I'm and hands
platform partners and leading the
potency group as a key member of the
analytical development team working with
fi h clinical and commercial products
supporting method transfers at CR OS
CMOS and regulatory submissions I will
now turn it over to Laura for her
presentation take it away good morning
and thank you all of you guys that I
should be this webinar it's a pleasure
for me to be here I wanted to thank the
psychics group for inviting me to give
this webinar and I just want to share
some of the work that we've been doing
at how i bind therapeutics so having
said that and go ahead and get started
so just wanted to share this this is
actually the slides come from a poster
that we recently presented at the WCB p
conference in washington DC a couple
last week so so all of the
misinformation is part of this poster
and I mean obviously you will have
access to it also I had the opportunity
to present this poster as well in the
lace conference in Santiago Chile which
which actually it was a very interesting
conferencing conference looking at Latin
American work on siiii so so just wanted
to share that with you okay now jumping
into the presentation because we all
know by compilation is one of the most
important post translational
modifications that may affect the
efficacy and immunogenicity of the
biotherapeutics in 14-day DCC and the
cdc and highlighted sophisticated
clients information in this presentation
the complementary of various liquid
phase by separation met
fact impaired including TV and some hplc
approaches that android consolation
analysis of a glycoprotein that we're
going to be looking at how fine
therapeutic glycoprotein has multiple
like oscillation sites and and how we
use orthogonal methods to demonstrate
how we do characterization to to
understand like a.m. link when
oscillation of our complex molecule and
also it's for like a historical approach
because we know what I wanted to show on
these slices our legacy methods and how
technology becomes available how we want
to continue to use these new methods
that we get increased sensitivity and
separation and as well can there the
ease of use is greatly improved so so we
of being a small company we contrast
most of our work to see our own HTML so
we spent a lot of time and method
transfer and if we can make if we can
transfer methods that are more sensitive
and and simple and eat and the ease of
use is better I mean that's what we all
I looking for so so so this is kind of a
little bit of the evolution of Halozyme
where we started where we want to be
moving forward with our NIH program and
and just I'm not going to focus a lot of
that up by the last bullets in terms of
the structures for our molecule but as
we all know there's public database that
that we use without mass spec data to
measure based on their to you values and
and I wanted to share some of the very
fast information that we were able to
obtain using the Science Kid method and
how we could compare it to our knowledge
that we already have and how this can
help us in the future for
early molecules to get a fast read on
what are my calculations profile maybe
so so some of the technology is that I'm
going to be talking about is the
capillary electrophoresis on the LC
three methods that we currently use it
at house I'm so the three methods that
I've been talking about is the two amino
acid acid by normal phase chromatography
and I'm going to go into actually the
details of the method that we currently
perform and just keep in mind that this
is our to a method is a legacy method
and I mean it has been improved and you
can make it a little faster but this is
the current method that we perform so so
it is very labor-intensive it could
potentially be a little less
labor-intensive but it's still quite a
bit and then we'll mention the rapid for
by hillock forma tog raphy that we are
currently validated in one of our CEO
TRL and the new science facts like in
Lego and analysis kids that actually I
just want to say a quick story I
actually attended one of these webinars
and I were they were talking about this
kit and I was very excited so so I was
able to get my hands on one of those
kids and trying on with our complex
molecule and this is kind of how this
whole poster went about so so we got
really excited with the data that we
were able to do so I'm really hoping
hoping that with this presentation I can
inspire you guys also to to see what's
out there to give it a try ok so i am
going to jump into the to a method that
we currently perform we still perform
because we're the process of
transferring for release and for some
characterization we intended continue to
use some of our torical methods but but
for
for release where the process I'm moving
to more of a simplified method for
personal of our our product and try new
products as well so i'm going to switch
over to the next slide because here
pretty much covers what i have in the
previous slide more the other detail and
it's always easier to see the pictures
versus the text so so just prior to give
you a quick quick overview this isn't
that our local protein we use about 175
micrograms and then that nature protein
is treated with the pngs at 37 degrees
and the Z glob population historically
been 16 to 24 hours then we have a clean
up step with we use a clean of cartridge
a new cartridge and that takes about one
to two hours depending on the amount of
sample that we have and then after that
we have to dry our samples honest
feedback and that could take greater
than four hours or sometimes even
overnight and then we continue with the
chewy labeling and and then after that
to a lil is a 65-degree for up to three
hours and then we have another clean up
step where we use a less cartridge and
that can take again up to one to two
hours and then again we drive on samples
greater than four hours overnight and
then we reconstitute in water and we
inject about fifty microliters for hplc
analysis and then on top of that I mean
our hplc run is usually it's 110 minutes
so it's pretty lengthy method and and as
you guys can see there's so many steps
involved so there's always possibilities
you know something go wrong or or we
have to start all over so so and there's
there's so many steps there's many
crypto it's multiple buffers that need
to be prepared and also in some of those
clean up steps is it's just we see high
variability in the amount of exercise
that stays in there so so having the
least it is a it isn't this method is
validated method but it is pretty
labor-intensive and one more thing I
want a dimension of course is hplc so we
do have to condition our call so that
takes an additional amount of time as
well so here I'm showing you really what
you like to want to see with that
profile looks like for our glycoprotein
so it doesn't have a significant amount
of Peaks there except separation is good
we are able to separate isolated species
but as you can see we disintegrate
things after probably around I don't
know exactly but it's probably around
the 15 minute time and everything prior
to that is considered part of the the
process of the sample prep so now moving
to a second method that we're currently
using is the the rapid for and left kids
and that's using the hillock
chromatography again I'm gonna sloot I'm
gonna skip this slide because I'm going
to go into the flow diagram that I think
it's easier to see so here we use a than
our glycoprotein about 15 micrograms and
it's the natured at 90 degrees for three
minutes and cool down and then the
denatured protein is treated with
endogenous with the enzyme for divine
oscillation and
she believed for five minutes and then
they get the endless light cans are
released from the lipoproteins as bipasa
means which react with the fluorescence
label so so we had a labeling reagents
for five minutes and and then and then
we add a season i trial and at this
point we do have a little palette that
we sent your piece down and then we just
are very careful in collecting from the
supernatant and we inject about I
believe it's around three to five
microliters for our hplc analysis so as
you guys can see this method is highly
it's a lot faster the sample preparation
is one less than an hour so it's a quite
improvement to the current 28 and it's
also mess background Lee the H there are
some of the hiccups that we find I mean
the hplc run is also 65 minutes so it's
kind of a long run and as we all know
hillock is very variable so so another
thing that we've actually had to spend
quite a bit of time is conditioning that
columns usually to commission columns
prior to to being able to use them for
prime method we have to spend a full day
in conditioning a column and we only get
about 16 to seven at this time and this
is in our hands I'm not saying this
applies for everybody but we get about
60 to 70 injections per column so so if
you have a lot of samples that this
could be problematic okay so and this is
what our profile reflects as you guys
can see it for us it's a quite improved
from our to a method we're getting
significant or peaks for our
in order to terrify specifications we
actually group these five hands into
multiple Keeks because otherwise it gets
very complicated so so as you can see
this is a very nice separation and we
get our nails recharge like ants again
that did that's a on the right of our
chromatogram so I did actually i would
just realize and I probably shouldn't
include the full profile because since
we don't do a cleanup step we do get a
lot of the excess I at the beginning of
our profile but it is quite separated so
it doesn't impact our quantitation but
and I do believe you are able to to do a
wash step if you want in the kid it
actually has the procedure to do that
but we didn't really think we needed to
do it so so but if you do that washed up
again you're getting more time and more
simple handling to the process ok so now
I'm going to move into the thigh ax
quick pitch that we currently started
evaluating at a house I'm and evident
switch over here I mean just keep in
mind all of these are for instance we
label total of course do we you would
need to have your presence detector so
here in terms of the thigh acts we have
our glycoprotein and you know i just
want to mention that they use actually
their magnetic beads which are
proprietary so everything here is in
solution so there's really no no inning
no centrifugation involved so it is a
sample handling it makes it very very
very simple so we have our our
glycoprotein where we add our bees our
nature
solution and B&H at 50 degrees for 8
minutes we cool down and then we have
our because copulation with irons I'm 60
degrees for 20 minutes and then we were
and then followed by so that I can
actually get captured by the magnetic
beads and then we had a feeling I trial
and and then we go we remove that but
Peter nitrile and and all of this is
actually pretty we use a magnetic rack I
know we have just started to use this so
we don't haven't tested a lot of samples
but I do understand that there's a
96-well plate magnetic you can also do
this on a 96 plan well played in for
high-throughput samples and that's kind
of where we want to go for our qbd
studies usually return and you when we
have to have a lot of samples we do
intend to use a 96-well platform we
haven't used that yet but we currently
use dis our magnetic rack and actually I
part of the kids they provide you with a
small magnetic I think for an individual
to but you can buy these when a wax from
anywhere so you can increase the amount
of samples that you you intend to use so
anyway going back to the method we do
you use your any pts for labeling at 50
degrees for 20 minutes and then clean up
with this heater nitrile and then you
really think I against from the beach
with water and then a really nice thing
is that your esee running time is only
seven minutes so that I mean we can
generate with we have an hour sample
prep we can generate data very very fast
and
that is I mean the process is really
invaluable there's minimal buffer
reagent preparation because everything
comes in the kit and obviously the
operational variability is greatly
reduced we do videos on high resolution
and chill capillary I believe they have
switched that to another capillary but
it should work the same way so here now
I'm showing you the profile and you can
see now we're getting even more peaks
which is great for characterization
that's kind of what we want to see and I
mean we optimized methods that we want
to get for the separation of all I by
hand species also there is an internal
standards if two internal standards that
that we that we include in your run and
this is actually really important of
course we do the corrected migration
times or calculations you need to have
that but in addition they have provided
us with a database that based on your
internal standards and I'm not quite
sure how it's called the GU database
that tie it to a variety of that you
actually just opened the database and
I'll show a digital data on this side I
just wanted to point out that you need
to have these internal standards to go
into that database to get the ID of your
clients without doing any mass spec work
just to get the initial ID I mean of
course you want to confirm that that is
accurate but in a couple of hours you
can have a full line of what you made
your glycans are and even though the
smaller ones because it allows you to
zoom in and we'll get the smaller Peaks
I mean we I'll show you some of our data
that we were able to count up to 80
Peaks on this profile so it could be
very very powerful when you're trying to
do
characterization and identifying some of
your smaller piece okay so this is I
know as a very busy table I tried to put
together comparing the three methods and
they all have great value and that our
lab we continue to use the three of them
so so I'm not saying one is better than
the other but what I do want to focus in
here is the sample preparation time
going from two to three days especially
if we as a small company have to
schedule time with the CRO or a TMO it
our price is going to go significantly
lower if they don't have to spend three
times three days analyzing our samples
and for the rapid floor it's really the
the sample preparation time is a little
less than an hour and for the fire pit
is about an hour so but the runtime up
self I mean seven minutes is actually
pretty wonderful and in addition there's
no calm conditioning I mean we all know
we have to recondition a capillary but
that happens very very quickly and
that's even built in within the seven
minutes between the seven minutes of
your run so so it makes it very very
good and I we haven't done too much work
with the site so i don't really can't
really say how many injections you can
do based on using one capillary but
based on our experience with the
previous kit you can do hundreds of
infections without any issues so anyway
i'm not going to go through this table
all this information is here and it's
pretty much just a compilation of the
previous slides so but I just didn't
want to focus on those two things that
are very important for us okay so here I
just wanted to share a little of some of
the work that we're currently doing as
you can see obviously we've measured our
identification
our clients by mass spec using the rapid
floor and and even with the two AAA
we've done we've done mass back on that
to get identification so now we kind of
wanted to confirm that the ideas that
we're gaining getting with a database
that fights has provided that at all yes
getting the same identifications and the
additional peaks that we've seen that we
can enhance those and measure them and
get an idea is to make sure we're
capturing all I glycans per our product
so so here just as you still we do with
the next to the hook like Hassan aid
digestion we did increase the size of
the capillary just ensure that we can
separate a lot of those small Peaks for
our ID but so this is just kind of a
snapchat of I mean what would anybody
would do to identify all done and Link
like ends that you have and here I just
kind of wanted to touch in into that GU
database that's why says provided so as
you can see this out of right away using
this database you can pull up your your
raw data file and you assign your your
internal standards and then it transfers
all it I mean you make sure that all the
peeps are are integrated and identify
and well all the people are integrated
and then it actually convert it in
creates a file into it and it's fitted
spits it out into itself and it gives
you all these uu x values and also with
the ID of the lycans if that that are in
the database if it's not in the database
you can add them or you can customize
the database to fit your
or your molecule so so it is a pretty
nifty tool that we found specially for
some of our new programs that we just
want to know right away that we don't
have way we haven't had time to look at
them aspect identification we right away
just go in there and can get an idea how
many high mannose or violated species we
have so here I just kind of want to
dance show you what the highest kids
looks like obviously and five times
faster than the highlight and we see
that in the separation and the sample
prep is one hour just like I said seven
in separation and then you get that
automated like and I need and it also i
don't know if I mentioned it also comes
with a preassembled cartridge which I
mean makes it pretty easy if you're a
see user you're used to building your
capillaries but when you get new analyst
so you're working with see arrows or
CMOS it just makes it a lot easier to
have the preassembled cartridge yeah so
this is kind of what the kids this is
what it looks like so in summary the
evaluation of multiple items like
oscillations to a brown methodologist by
cee and LC and as a law allows increased
characterization of the theory of
glycoproteins and supports manufacturing
consistency I mean anybody in biotechs
have to do this and this presentation
demonstrates as the new science s
question level analysis kids can be used
as a compliment for our current hplc
methodologies and the identification of
the handle and glycosylated species and
the minor glycan structures can be
easily detected and structurally
elucidated by having the fire fast like
in labeling an analysis kit complement
the wrath of Florida lcms kit and then
the side-by-side compares comparison
delivers advil and resolving power to
separate positional and linkage island
life and this the complete defiance at
cycle labeling analysis kids has an
increased sensitivity and decreased
sample preparation complexities these
new methods allowed to get greater
conferences confidence and understanding
of our manufacturing consistency
demonstrating that all these orthogonal
methods on complementary in the
characterization of complex Keiko
protein and I just want to do is
knowledge some of the highest folks that
that that have been instrumental in
training up and giving the support with
a few new kit and analyse and marks of
science and math that is currently
introduced me and then from from our lab
I mean an additional people Tia and Mike
levar that is incredibly he's our CSO
and he's a gutted exported and bringing
in new technology even for our small
company and that is all I have and I
wanted also to thank the audience and
for for attending this short seminar and
and precise to inviting me again so
that's all I have thank you very much
Laura and as hopefully everybody can see
a quick poll question popped up and if
you could just take a couple of seconds
to answer that after seeing this
presentation you plan to implement
sea-based and glycan analysis in your
lab yes and 0 6 months 7 to 12 months
for 12-plus months or not at this time
we'll give everybody gets a couple more
seconds I think to answer that
with that I want to thank you laura for
that wonderful presentation and before
we get started on the question and
answer session i would like to remind
our audience how to submit questions you
can submit questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
and we'll try to get to as many
questions as we can so it looks like we
do have a couple of questions we'll go
ahead and get started with these Laura
the first is how many samples can you
analyze using these I x faster I can
kids so the kid is intended to analyze
up to 100 sample thank you the next
question is what is to aa2 is a benign
sonic acid it is a labeling reagent and
for us we got then you can use purpose
and flailing and the next question is
rapid just pee and JS f was used for two
AAA and wrapping floor methods do you
know why the incubation times ranged
from 16 plus hours to only three minutes
um i really don't know i know the rapid
death that we use for the 2a comes in a
kit as well so so probably I don't know
if the concentrations or what is in that
rapid jess is different from one kid to
another i am not quite sure okay it
looks like we might have at least one
more question here what n-glycans
standards do you use for cee or with the
rapid floor system so so the standards
internal scan
is that we got our pain from the kid so
I am not sure what they really are
because they're not really labeled with
what what they are I don't know if
science can maybe provide you that
answer I know in the past we were using
the mouth of hep toes and and now they
call them d3 and d1 and d3 and I'm not
quite sure what it is I'm sorry I don't
know the answer okay we've got a couple
a couple more questions here one is how
many samples do you typically run per
week and what would improve your
workflow so it really depends I mean in
our lab we since we contract things out
we we are just working on our li-fi
eight and it depends what the stage of a
program we can be running up to 40
samples in one week at a time or we can
be running five samples depends on what
the level of work that we're doing and
how many programs we're doing I know in
RC arrows I mean we constantly have
manufacturing laws that they're they're
testing for us and also stability and I
stability program for some of our
problems we include glycans as we wrap
up with some QbD testings we do end up
getting hundreds even hundreds of
samples at a time so it really varies
sometimes we test five and one week and
sometimes we could test up to 100 thank
you the next question is is it necessary
to do triplicate analysis for each
sample
I don't believe we do triple kept
analysis for each sample I would have to
look at our validated methods and what
we do but I don't believe we do triple
get analysis I mean we do have
bracketing standards where we have up to
triplicates of our bracketing standards
and our methods but for our individual
samples we do not and the next question
is you mentioned the lab is still doing
all three techniques what's the reason
for this um we are still continuing to
use the to a method because that is the
method that we have filed and it's
currently approved so until we have
enough data and we get approval from the
agency that we can move on to the next
methods we have to continue to do that
for our program so that's basically the
reason why we still continue to do the
two AAA next is what kind of injection
method is used for this analysis and
will it affect sample composition I'm
assuming the question has to do with cee
it is a pressure injection and I mean
since there's no electric or not it's
not electrokinetic injection it doesn't
affect the the competition because we're
not selectively pulling in so it's only
a pressure injection by see the next
question is is this method suitable for
glycolipids
I'm sorry I don't know the answer to
that question I don't we don't really
work with glycolipids so I'm not sure
the next question is has an attempt at
automating the sample prep been made um
we have not yet yet but that's what we
intend to do and actually at WC BP I did
attend the Phi X seminar and they
actually had some great examples are on
automating this and using a robot in and
doing 96-well plates so I know it's
possible and they have done it so your
best bet is contacting them and getting
their presentation on that we have not
done that yet okay um and there is one
more question about Ken glycopeptides be
analyzed with the p800 + c e lift yeah
they'll see why not
okay at this point I would like to thank
the audience for all of your questions
and i would like to once again thank
laura salmeron for her great
presentation on anglican profiling Laura
do you have any final comments before we
sign off now I just wanted to thank the
audience also for pretending this
presentation and and and if there's any
future questions you have I mean you can
feel free to contact me i'm in linkedin
and i'll be happy to share any of the
information that i can well thank you
again Laura and just as a reminder
today's educational webcast with
sponsored by psychic separations and you
can find more information on the fast
glidecam kit by visiting science calm
forward slash fast glycan that's fa st g
ly CA n and today's webcast will be
available on demand through august of
this year and you will receive an email
from libraries alerting you when the
webcast is available for replay we
invite you to forward that announcement
to any of your colleagues who might have
missed today's live event and we'll see
you next time goodbye